from Philadelphia bar owners to Pawnee
government officials from New York admin
to Russian spies TV has only kept
getting better over the past decade it's
hard to narrow down the best offerings
but we stand by these as the best
television shows airing during the 2010
a show about five dead beat lowlifes
running a bar in South Philadelphia
doesn't exactly sound like a comedic
gold mine right off the bat but for
better or for worse It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia has defied all the odds
four years after it got off to a
relatively inconspicuous and super cheap
start in 2005 the show continued through
the entire following decade truly
becoming a comedy staple of the 2010s
when it was renewed for its 14th season
it officially tied The Adventures of
Ozzie and Harriet as the longest-running
live-action sitcom of all time which
might be the only way those two shows
can be compared to each other shorts are
white trash do not call the shorts white
trash so how exactly is sunny stayed so
fresh over nearly 15 years thanks to
brilliant scripts by co-creators Rob
McElhenney Glenn Howerton and Charlie
Day also played Mack Dennis and Charlie
respectively this totally bizarre sitcom
has kept things new and exciting even as
it enters the 2020s from its innovative
approach to current issues two insane
board games ill-advised child beauty
pageants the best plane trip of all time
the gang always keeps things interesting
and the series even manages to hit its
emotional beats without seeming
inauthentic at the end of the show's
thirteenth season Mac came out to his
father in a gorgeously choreographed
dance proving that always sunny will
always be relevant no matter how long
it's on the air as the spiritual
successor to the office NBC's other
mockumentary Parks and Recreation had
huge shoes to fill ultimately it
succeeded by creating an entirely
different show and relying on pure
positivity rather than cringe humor the
story of a small government department
in Pawnee Indiana led by the intrepid
and overly intense Leslie Knope in an
arguably career-defining role from Amy
Poehler Parks and Rec taught audiences
that they could achieve anything they
wanted even if your life takes some
unexpected turns
with the supporting cast
has to round it out by future stars like
Chris Pratt Aziz Ansari Aubrey Plaza and
Adam Scott alongside established stars
like Rob Lowe and rashida Jones the show
always survived on sheer optimism even
as it repeatedly phased cancellation
throughout its run Parks and Rec
remained one of the most cheerful and
sunny shows on television letting its
characters fail learn succeed and grow
in realistic ways that rewarded its fans
as well as its talented cast from its
many standout moments to its
pitch-perfect finale it's a show that
earned its place in television history
without having to stand in the shadow of
the office at all zombies were all the
rage during the 2000s and in 2010 AMC
took advantage of the trend with the
series premiere of The Walking Dead
based on a comic book series written by
Robert Kirkman the show opens on Rick
Grimes played by Andrew Lincoln in a
role about as far from Love Actually as
he could get as he wakes up from a coma
only to discover that the world has
fallen into ruin after wandering through
a desolate Atlanta he eventually finds
other survivors and must join forces
with them to fight against hordes of the
undead to rout ten seasons The Walking
Dead has gifted audiences with
unforgettable heroes like Rick Michonne
and Glenn it's also given us formidable
villains like negan played with sadistic
glee by Jeffrey Dean Morgan together
they paint a bleak and yet somehow
optimistic portrait of humanity as they
face down the most terrifying threat
possible thanks to creative storytelling
and impeccable action The Walking Dead
has earned a place as one of the most
unforgettable shows of the 2010s and it
seems poised to continue for years to
come ever since the Silence of the Lambs
swept the Academy Awards in 1992
audiences have been fascinated with
author Thomas Harris's elegant cannibal
dr. Hannibal Lecter showrunner Bryan
Fuller capitalized on the fictional
serial killer with his critically adored
series Hannibal which ran for three
seasons between 2013 and 2015 with mass
Mickelson as the title killer and Hugh
Dancy as an FBI investigator will Graham
who finds himself caught up in
Hannibal's tangled web of mind games and
dark indulgences the show was adored by
its fans how does one politely
is a dish in circumstances such as these
one doesn't
thanks to Fuller's trademark visual
flourishes and creative storytelling
hannibal made its mark on television as
a whole despite the fact that it was
cancelled by NBC due to low ratings it
still regarded as one of the best shows
of the modern era
it's legion of fanta balls still pine
for more even though the series finale
brought the complex relationship between
its protagonists to a perfect crescendo
spy thrillers have always been popular
and in 2013 FX struck gold with the
Americans this cold war thriller focused
on two Russian spies Elizabeth and
Philip Jennings played by Keri Russell
and Matthew Reese masquerading as
everyday Americans during one of the
most fraught and tense periods in
American history aside from hiding their
true identities from their friends and
neighbors they must also keep their
terrible secret from their children who
were born as American citizens it
doesn't help that their neighbor and
good friend Stan Beeman happens to be an
FBI agent
throughout six gripping seasons the
Americans perfectly encapsulated turmoil
of the Cold War while telling the
personal story of the Jennings their
undercover colleagues and their friends
she's trained for this the show features
powerhouse performances by Russell and
Reese whose on-screen chemistry led to
the two of them striking up a romance on
set and having a channel together in
2016 it also boasts incisive writing and
direction especially in its final season
landing it firmly on the list of the
best shows of the 2010s in the opening
moments of the good plays the audience
meets Eleanor she'll strop played by
Kristen Bell she has just been given
some good news and some bad news by
Michael played by Ted Danson she
recently died but on the upside she made
it into the afterlife called the good
place as she spends more time in
paradise
Eleanor starts to realize that something
just isn't right and eventually she
confesses to her soulmate
Chiti that there's been some sort of
mistake and she actually doesn't belong
here I'm not supposed to be here
[Music]
wait what that's just the first twist of
the good places debut season and anyone
who sits down and watches this
innovative show will be rewarded through
every unbelievable twist and turn it
takes alongside t v-- veterans like bel
and dancin the cast is mostly made up of
fresh faces including William Jackson
Harper who co-stars as the critically
indecisive Chiti Manny Jacinto who plays
Florida dirtbag Jason who himself
sometimes masquerades as a silent
buddhist monk in a breakout role darcy
Cardon plays Janet and all-knowing sort
of human Alexa device and British
television presenter Jameela Jamil plays
the oblivious name-dropping socialite to
honey though it might feel like you're
in the bad place when you hear that the
good place is calling it quits with the
end of its fourth season in 2020 sure
and his team certainly know what they're
doing with sharp writing and what seems
like a new twist every episode
they've gifted audiences with one of the
most innovative sitcoms in recent memory
one of the defining dramatic shows of
the entire 21st century thus far has
been AMC's Mad Men which starred Jon
Hamm as the enigmatic and mysterious Don
Draper a suave smooth-talking New York
City ad man with secrets to hide led by
a showrunner who is a veteran of The
Sopranos the rest of Mad Men's cast was
rounded out by talented performers like
Elisabeth Moss January Jones John
Slattery Christina Hendricks and more
the end result was a group of
extraordinary actors playing characters
who were each given their own complex
emotional journeys ultimately the series
covered all of the 1960s recreating
moments like the moon landing the
assassination of JFK and more all set
against Don Draper's extraordinarily
turbulent life by the end of the show
Don's life is in tatters after betraying
his second wife Megan he finds himself
alone in California and seemingly
contemplating ending it all
but just as the series ends he takes a
turn thanks to a tranquil seaside resort
in the story's final moments we see done
sitting on a cliffside meditating
quietly and then breaking into a
mysterious smile followed by one of
coca-cola's most famous real-world ads
insinuating that Don himself came up
with it
in capitalist inspiration during
meditation would be a classic Don move
and though the ending is largely
ambiguous it's a perfect finish for Mad
Men's overall journey cementing it as a
classic of the decade when it first
premiered in 2011 Game of Thrones
probably seemed like an unlikely success
for HBO an adaptation of George RR
Martin's sprawling fantasy series A Song
of Ice and Fire the show named after the
first book in the series stuck
faithfully to Martin's narrative set in
the fictional region of Westeros Thrones
spent most of the decade selling the
story of its most powerful players all
of whom spend the entire series fighting
for the Iron Throne from the dragon
Queen Daenerys Targaryen to the
power-hungry Cersei Lannister to the
conflicted but Noble Jon Snow the iron
throne was up for grabs to any number of
qualified candidates and for years
diehard fans tuned in to see who would
win the game in the end when people ask
you what happened here tells me one else
remembers as it turned out Game of
Thrones ended not with a bang but with a
whimper thanks to a poorly plotted final
season and an unsatisfying inheritor of
thrown fans flocked to the Internet to
express their extreme displeasure still
disappointing final season doesn't undo
Thrones legacy as one of the last great
examples of a show that everyone had to
make time for each week Thrones changed
TV for the better and it remains one of
the most impressive accomplishments on
television in recent memory there have
been plenty of political television
shows throughout the years but few of
them have been as cruel incisive and
hilarious as veep the series was led by
Julia Louie Dreyfus as the titular vice
president Selina Meyer whose political
dreams were crushed at the beginning of
the series as she was relegated to the
second place spot alongside an unseen
president through it all beep never
shied away from showing the dark
underbelly of Washington DC from
underhanded deals to vicious insults to
destructive policies they're calling you
the no BS VP damn right I mean I lied
and everything but it sounded
please Selena is aided and abetted by
her equally corrupt team including
bagman and eternally loyal right-hand
man Gary chief of staff Amy
communications expert Dan speechwriter
Mike and arrogant White House liaison
Jonah unfortunately they can't stop her
constant gaps as she makes political
fumbles over and over again despite the
odds she ends up serving as president of
the United States multiple times thanks
to a tour de force performance by
louis-dreyfus some of the sharpest
riding on television and a pitch-perfect
supporting cast
beep hit all the right notes even while
it made you concerned about the state of
American politics animated series for
adults filled the airwaves during the
first two decades of the 21st century
and though there are plenty of excellent
examples a stand out series was
Netflix's Bojack horseman created by
Raphael bob-waksberg said in a surreal
world populated with normal humans as
well as anthropomorphic talking animals
who act exactly like humans the show
followed its title character voiced by
Will Arnett Bojack is a washed-up sitcom
star who is constantly trying to regain
celebrity having starred in the once
popular series horsing around as he
plans his return to the public eye
Bojack works with Diane Ewan played by
Community & Glow star Alison Brie a
Ghost Rider he hires to help write his
autobiography through it all the angles
with his cat agent Princess Carolyne and
butts heads with the sitcom nemesis mr.
peanut butter I have nothing to show for
the life that I've lived and I have
nobody in my life who's better off for
having known me that isn't true
isn't it though despite the seemingly
ridiculous premise bob-waksberg and his
impeccable voice cast use their platform
to address issues like clinical
depression and marital strife proving
that there's so much more to Bojack
horseman than initially meets the eye
Fifi Waller Bridges one-woman show
turned television sensation fleabag only
ran for two seasons but it made an
undeniably explosive impact during that
short amount of time the first season of
this bleak half-hour comedy stars Waller
bridge herself as fleabag a single
depressed and uninhibited London woman
with little direction in her life
the main character struggles with her
best friend's untimely death while she
tries to maintain relationships with her
difficult family and series of
boyfriends throughout the show she
constantly breaks the fourth wall
treating the viewer like a best friend
for whom she hides absolutely nothing
while her bridge was originally
reluctant about a second season but
audiences are lucky she went for it in
2019 the showrunner released a
thoughtful emotional and beautifully
crafted second season in which fleabag
forms a confusing relationship with a
priest played by Andrew Scott this is a
love story between its engaging
storytelling its talented roster of
series regulars and guest stars which
includes everyone from Olivia Colman to
Kristin Scott Thomas and Waller bridges
beautifully unique boys fleabag is one
of the best reviewed shows to hit the
airwaves of years at the 2019 Emmys it
dominated the conversation even taking
the top prize from the final season of
beat Waller bridge says she's definitely
done with the character now and while
that might be disappointing for some
fans it also means that fleabag can
remain impeccable unchanged and
endlessly rewatchable ever since his
time on community Donald Glover has been
a talent to watch he proved himself on
the small screen once again in 2016 with
FX's Atlanta in which he stars as well
as writes directs and produces lover
plays earned who's trying to make his
way in Atlanta when he realizes that his
talented cousin Alfred who wraps his
paper boy might have what it takes to
make it if paper boy can make it with
earns help then earn might be able to
reunite with his daughter in a strange
girlfriend over just two seasons Atlanta
has become one of the most talked about
shows of the decade earning universal
praise for Glover's performance and
behind-the-scenes work in the show's
second season
subtitled Robin season Glover took even
more risks and they've paid off
handsomely with things like the creepy
riveting and unforgettable Teddy Perkins
episode actually the first person to be
Indian feel free to Twitter a blogspot
any of it you know what like some kind
of rush
lever even became the first African
American artist to win an Emmy for
directing a comedy series so as long as
Glover wants to stay in Atlanta
fans and critics alike will definitely
tune in and anyone who's watched the
show just can't wait to see what he does
next Netflix has produced plenty of
hugely successful original shows but few
have been is heavily discussed and
stirred up as much excitement as
stranger things a show from the duffer
brothers that first hit the streaming
service in 2016
sets in the seemingly sleepy town of
Hawkins Indiana stranger things
introduced viewers to the frightening
dimension of the upside-down and
monsters like the demo Gorgon its story
began with the sudden disappearance of
young will buyers and the efforts by his
friends and family to find him as they
delve deeper into the unexpected and
sinister world that lies beneath Hawkins
wills friend Mike befriends a mysterious
girl who goes by eleven and turns out to
have surprising special powers stranger
things has earned praise and adoration
for its clever plotting party sense of
humor and outstanding young cast all of
whom have skyrocketed to fame since the
show debuted alongside this new
generation of actors veterans like
Winona Ryder Sean Astin and David Harbor
delivered excellent performances as well
making sure that the adults of stranger
things are just as compelling as the
kids after dominating the second half of
the decade stranger things shows no
signs of slowing down especially after a
cliffhanger capped off its third season
in 2019 there are too few shows that
Chronicle the pure joys of female
friendship but in 2014
creators and show runners Abbi Jacobson
and Ilana Glazer gifted the world with
broad city this laughs out loud comedy
is an unflinching exploration of the
highs and lows of the particularly
intense relationship between its stars
fictional counterparts also named Abbi
and Ilana the two comedians met while
studying at New York City's Upright
Citizens Brigade and after they produced
broad city as a web series UCB founder
Amy Poehler took notice
before long the comedy star was serving
as executive producer alongside Jacobson
and Glazer when the series moved Comedy
Central to begin its official run from
romantic mishaps to counterfeit bags to
outlandish outfits broad city covered
every possible part of Abby and Alana's
lives relationships and enduring
friendship leaving no stone unturned no
matter how grotesque broad city always
pushed the limits but it also provided
honest emotional moment
giving it a dynamic unlike any other
show that aired in the past ten years
adapting a beloved classic film into a
television show can be a tricky endeavor
and lead to middling results but thanks
to excellent scripts and a revolving
door of talented actors showrunner Noah
Hawley succeeded with 2014's Fargo the
show is adapted from the award-winning
1996 Coen Brothers film of the same name
and the Academy Award winning duo also
lent their names to the project as
executive producers giving it even more
prestige an anthology series that airs
on FX
Fargo features a different cast and
focuses on a different story for each
season but it cleverly includes some
overlap between the stories to make sure
each one is connected of course every
season features plenty of Sly Coen
references for their diehard fans with a
cadre of incredible actors like Ian
McGregor gene smart Billy Bob Thornton
Martin Freeman and more audiences will
definitely remain riveted by Fargo or
however long Holly keeps the show going
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]